texas governor greg abbott announced the
end of the statewide mass
mandate allowing businesses now to
reopen full capacity
failed california governor gavin newsom
now in the middle of a possible recall
says it was reckless
and by the way he was caught again in a
restaurant but he claims i didn't eat
in the restaurant bozo o'rourke called
it a death warrant meanwhile up on
capitol hill
democrats are continuing to charge
forward with their attack on election
integrity with h.r 1 which would
massively
expand mainland uh voting ballot
harvesting
uh create the perfect storm for election
chaos
and yeah no id and felons get to vote
no one person knows more about any of
more of this and kaylee mcenany who we
can now officially
welcome as a member of our fox news
family we're glad to have you kaylee
thank you congratulations
thank you good to join you sean well i
did notice that jen sake
she was asked if she had any good wishes
for you or if she'd join you
and she said sure
question would that you be open to that
i'll open up my program
i'd love she's willing to do a wide
range of programs
i'd love circle back ken saki to come
back on this program
do you think you were treated as the way
she is treated
were you treated differently oh i think
it's obvious to anyone who
has watched the press briefings it was
an entirely different treatment by the
press i mean for one she was asked
what joe biden thought of the antifa
riots and
you know her answer was that she hadn't
spoken to him if i would have given an
answer
like that it would have been
unacceptable the headlines would have
been egregious and appalling
afterward look i respect her for saying
that she would be willing to go
on fox she has been on fox and networks
that will challenge her as they should
but you know what i guess my question is
where's joe it's been 41 days
uh at this point president trump had had
multiple
press appearances press conference
president barack obama had as well
joe biden needs to step up we need to
hear from him uh he needs to engage
in the transparency that he promised us
he hasn't thus far okay now she's went
on fox news sunday
that's on the fox broadcast network um
if she really wants a diversity of views
now i'll make two offers to her she can
come on with me
one-on-one love to have her or i will
let her debate you
or discuss the issues uh of the day
but uh i guess she'll circle back with
me on that or what do you think
hey i would love to see uh you interview
the press secretary sean you would have
some
hard-hitting questions that man
conservatives would want to hear from
number one why is it that under
president donald trump they talk about
cages that were falsely attributed to
him
in the immigration context that indeed
were put in place by president barack
obama and then of course now we know
these immigration facilities are opened
uh but there's no criticism there we've
seen peter ducey ask questions about
this but
i would love to see motto amano uh sean
hannity
and the press secretary that would be a
lot of fun to watch i'd like to get an
answer tara reid
and a woman by the name miss flores
accused joe biden in this
recent campaign of inappropriate
behavior
we've seen a lot of creepy videos of
joe's sniffing hair and
and touching and in people's face and
it was frankly bizarre um does
if she if joe supports the investigation
in a cuomo
should there be one into joe that's a
fair question no
all of those should be asked sean on my
first day i mean if you think of the
questions i was asked at the podium
i was asked about allegations of that
nature that were false allegations
but allegations nonetheless against the
president i was asked if i would ever
lie to the press
um i said no and i kept my word i never
did we had footnotes to everything
we ever said but those are the flavor
and the variety of questions i was asked
at the podium and by the way we had to
anticipate
at the podium but those are questions um
we we've heard crickets we
they just don't simply get that degree
of scrutiny in a democratic minister
administration as you would in a donald
trump administration well you did an
impressive job and i don't know how you
did it
there's not enough money on this earth
to make me well actually i might do it
just for fun
you know there is a fun aspect to that
um at moments but you did a great job
we're uh honored to have you here thank
you so much for being with us and we're
uh we're looking forward to having you
on a lot thank you